il y a eu le céleri on a même dit qu'il
se vendait à 6 dollars mais en juin le
prix des autres légumes a aussi grimpé
en moyenne de 17% sont compare avec juin
qu'est ce qui explique cette flambée des
prix quoi faire pour continuer de manger
des légumes à prix raisonnable on en
parle d'ailleurs avec maxime laplante
président de l'union paysanne bonjour
monsieur laplante
bonjour monsieur bourque qu'est ce qui
explique cette augmentation sur le prix
des légumes souvent au second point que
la météo des conditions météorologiques
sont défavorables dans les régions
agricoles et pas seulement ici au québec
le ça peut être aussi du côté des états
unis
quelle est votre lecture vous c'est ce
que l'essentiel des produits qu'on
retrouve sur les épiciers du québec eut
une d'étrangers leurs états unis mexique
ou amérique du sud moi ce que je
constate juste que je développe lorsque
je parlais des producteurs c'est qu'à la
ferme le plie pas changé mais je trouve
que les conditions météo ils ont le dos
large
[Musique]
donc je serai ce serait davantage on
pourrait dire les produits qui sont
reportés en juin l'augmentation et c'est
assez constat est assez cocasse était la
même au niveau de la sphère ne le cheval
peut de distribution pour l'instant mais
au niveau de la firme exemple j'ai dû
reporter une partie des récoltes
je me donne pas le pouvoir de dieu avec
le suivant que je recharge est 50% plus
cher
je suis astreint au prix qu'on va me
donner puis ça vient de s'éteindre
j'en ai parlé avec un paquet producteurs
de quelques jours encore pu même des
organismes qui s'occupent de mise en
marché des produits août à maré chic que
céréales y puis non même au contraire
dans le code et cyrielle ils ont
constaté une baisse du pin bon fait
porter les conditions météo étaient pas
vraiment favorables ont eu un temps
extrêmement difficiles je l'avais aussi
borges est tout seul a tant que
producteur ne nous donnent aucun pouvoir
de dire ben oui c'était épouvantable
donc je monte mes prix de 20% pas du
tout même
encore les uns des prix sont restés
séparés ou même on diminue les
variations depuis ne sont pas
attribuables à des augmentations de prix
pour les producteurs c'est davantage
peut-être à la distribution qu'une
hausse actuellement et effectivement
c'est le constat de tous les gens qui
jamais par lise pose la question mais
comment ça se fait qu'on obtienne une
une hausse de prix de 10 ou de 20 % au
détail à l'épicé mais que nous en tant
qu'auditeur on voit rien passé de tout
ça si on comprend qu'il ya un jus
d'offre et de demande puis que en pleine
période estivale
à l'aube des vacances des fois c'est
tentant de diviser les gens ont sont
plus d'un dans l'esprit de dépenser il
ya un petit budget pour sortir ils vont
au moins se pose la question parce que
là il va le faire du camping
bon donc un jeu qui peut se faire le bon
je suis mal placé pour mettre le doigt
est exactement sur quel est le vrai
facteur qui fait en sorte que le pied
l'épicerie augmenter de 10 ou 20%
mais ce que je peux vous et c'est qu'au
niveau des producteurs oui ça va changer
et avec l'arrivée aussi des produits de
saison les produits dits sion peut
s'attendre à voir le prix redescendent
parce qu'on a toujours l'exemple vous
savez du fameux séderie à 6 dollars et
des effets de mode évidemment dit que le
jus de célérité très très bon de la
santé bon on peut s'attendre évidemment
donc avec les produits d'ici à voir les
prix retourner vers le bol
effectivement que le guide alimentaire
canadien ou aussi qui a été largement
modifié qui suggère la consommation de
plus de fruits de légumes donc c'est sûr
que présentement et il est plus facile
de bien poser une hausse des prix dans
ce domaine là si le guide alimentaire
canadien de dia est vraiment j'ai plus
de patate peut-être le petit monde
pourrait s'attendre mais ce que les gens
essaient de profiter d'une hausse du
prix des pâtes mais encore de moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est au niveau des pros du
temps il faut qu'on en arrive à avoir
une structure de prix ou détails qui
reculent un peu plus ce qu'est ce qui
est payé à la corne répond mais qu'est
ce que les gens peuvent faire pour
savoir ce que j'allais vous demander un
petit truc pour épargner est-ce que
c'est pas justement de fréquenter les
marchés publics d'acheter davantage chez
les producteurs d'ici c'est un peu ça
effectivement c'est de supprimer les
intermédiaires parce que j'ai fini lui
est en mesure de dire non mais moi ça me
quitte à en produire les mises en garde
et un la machine des macoutes et ans
s'est fait un nom qui est capable
d'établir son pré production de dire
écoutez moi c'est compliqué ça ça me
coûte ça produit dont je danse comme
compris donc que des contacts directs
soit marchés publics ou soit directement
la firme sait ce que c'est la meilleure
condition pour que le gris reflète un
peu plus l'arrêt a géré et comment on
peut faire pour s'approvisionner à
l'année donc chez les producteurs parce
qu'évidemment donc sur un niveau tout
petit peu plus copié elle et les fameux
paniers bio comment on peut faire encore
de même même temps que des paninis lieu
beaucoup de légumes de conservation avec
sont en développement présentement à
l'époque censément patate n'avait les
carottes mais maintenant on observe une
augmentation de la diversité de légumes
de conservation que ce soit dans les
courges accessoires et même il ya
possibilité de plus en plus avec des
serres tunnel d'étirer la saison donc on
peu aidé en mesure de de produire des
légumes feuilles beaucoup plus tôt que
ce qu'on faisait à 20 ou même beaucoup
plus tôt au printemps et boulder que
moyen s'est dit mais c'est sûr que dans
une plaie crû de l'hiver est seulement à
moins d'avoir une production en serre
mais ce qui est possible si messi ou
sincèrement que s'approvisionner en
débuterait au québec présentement la mi
janvier c'est effectivement un peu plus
difficile on comptait encore le soir sur
l'importation donc des légumes d'ici un
peu plus longtemps davantage diversifiée
ça c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle
merci beaucoup monsieur laplante
tu peux